alors si vous voulez une bonne histoire
belge pour vos concitoyens
alors c'est le belge dans une main il a
une pince à épiler et dans l'autre
maiden ou d'hommes alors il dit ça a été
ça efface n'est pas malade
bonjour aux ce que vous savez comment
est-ce qu'on tue un français non je ne
sais pas bien il suffit bêtement du tir
et 10 cm au dessus de la tête
et pourquoi mais comme ça voulu tuer son
complexe de supériorité
vous savez pourquoi le lion de waterloo
étaient tournés vers l'angleterre
je ne tiens pas non pour montrer son
coût français je vous écoute je
racontais sur cette belle du crisp
romanet qui voit un français avec un
suppositoire pendu autour du cou et lui
dit qu'elle mêle pour que tu te promènes
avec ça autour du cou c'est le médecin
qui m'a dit de suspendre nos traitements
c'est ça c'est pourquoi le chirurgien
français met des gants et des masques
une drop et non pour pas très connu des
ratés
est ce que vous savez pourquoi il n'a
pas de clé rage sur l'autoroute mais
parce que les françaises prennent tous
pour des lumières des différents ce qui
a trait à flot c'est la belgique est
image de fille
et bien il suffit de les regarder a
marre des rumeurs de la france et va
tourner son paquet va regarder leur
match inaugural de malchance au quesnoy
et garde le rhin
c'est pourquoi des français est toujours
des nôtres 0 à l'école parce qu'il ya
tant d'autres plus basse jamais pourquoi
on fait comme on dit les jours on tond
l'herbe sur le bord des autoroutes deux
fois par an en belgique ne savait pas
parce qu'on fournit les français deux
fois par an hors tabac
nous les belges on va charger drapeau
français inspirés de mettre le drapeau
blanc avec un brio mieux après guy parce
que des français c'est le fallait c'est
tout et cloches autour d'un vrai que
c'est beaucoup les français ils tournent
autour de l'école en courant ils
poursuivent leurs études dans cette
histoire à conter l'histoire alors une
chance aux français
[Musique]